[Music]
so for humans to live on Mars and not
just making a lot of potatoes and live
off the potatoes for a while it's just
the habitat the systems itself for a
robust life support system that's going
to keep you alive for this you know long
period of time I mean we go to the Space
Station that's been up there since 2000
and it's been working but we have a you
know agent well like a day and a half
trip to get something to the Space
Station if something fails we need a
spare part Mars just gonna take six to
eight months to get something there so
trying to build systems that are you
know super redundant but also have ways
to fix things like with you know 3d
printing I mean that's another thing
that we have ones on the space station
but we haven't had to utilize it for
making things that are critical they're
Institute right there so I think that's
that's one of the things a habitat
that's it's you know bulletproof the
food aspects you know eating food this
not only you know the taste good but
it's also has the nutritional value that
you're going to get all the the
nutrients that you need to function to
live for this extended period of time
you know the Martian environment is very
harsh you know with the thin atmosphere
3/8 gee you know solar radiation all
these things building suits that can
handle that when you're doing these
excursions and going out and cleaning
the solar panels and doing these things
having robust systems it will keep you
alive and then just you know water and
and in food you know I think I heard
it's gonna take 24,000 pounds of food
for I think a colony of four or five to
live up there so the pre position do you
fly those in pre position that there and
hope that a dust storm or something
doesn't wipe it out and know that it's
still there and then a shelf life of
five years whereas the shelf life for
the food on the space station is 18
months so a five year shelf shelf life
and every time item of food you know
sits there for another month another
month and
month it lives this nutritional value it
loses flavor it loses texture so making
sure that we have something that people
don't want to eat and will eat to stay
healthy on this in this environment we
as a race the human race are
intrinsically curious and we are wired
in our DNA as it we're explorers we look
up at the night sky we wonder what's up
there especially as children and so this
this journey of exploring the things
around us whether their clothes are far
that's what we do that's what we do as
humans and I think you know all the
things that we've done with exploration
whether it's walking on the moon or
building an International Space Station
all these things help advance life back
on earth and so exploration leads us to
a better life you know
heart pacemakers smoke detectors all
these things that have come out of the
space program but it's also not just the
technological things but it's the part
that brings us together as a humanity I
was in space on my first mission with
you know african-american asian-american
French German Russian the first female
commander people used to fight against
her now breaking bread at 17,500 miles
per hour going around the planet every
90 minutes seeing a sunrise and a sunset
every 45 while breaking bread listening
to shot a smooth operator okay that was
surreal that that blew my mind and they
gave me this perspective shift when I
look back at the planet you know like
Ron Garren's book orbital perspective
and so as we do this space station thing
as we maybe move go back to the moon and
build a habitat but eventually we're
going to be going to another planet and
Mars is you know our closest neighbor
that we can get to there potential
resources there
you know there's water at the poles
there's you know these iron is in the
soil that we can turn into other things
that perchlorates and so I think as a as
a race of people I think it's imperative
that we continue to explore but also
that we visit this neighbor that might
have been like our planet at one time
before so this can be a harbinger of
maybe things to come that we need to
understand
would what happened there and what's
going to potentially happen here on
earth you know no matter what that
timeframe is understanding that is is
very important
[Music]